[Music]  Jennifer Lopez electrified the annual  Macy's fourth of July fireworks  spectacular of course dressed to the  nines in this super sexy double cutout  fie high gown  the singer took the stage to debut her  new Spanish single with gente de zona  called knee to knee Oh  [Music]  the song isn't just a hit with fans her  boyfriend Alex Rodriguez seems to love  it too  he instagrammed this cute video just  hours before J Lo's performance aired  it's no surprise a rod loves his ladies  new music here's what JLo told et in  April  has Alex heard the news he had he loves  it he loves it and I'm so excited you  know every time I finished something I  bring it home and I want him to hear it  and he he's he's so supportive he's such  a supportive person and he's so lovely  [Music]  you